bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 ce soir nous parlerons
des 10 ans de l'association laurette
fugain une association évinoise qui
lutte contre la leucémie
il sera également question du cheval à
l'occasion la fête du cheval qui aura
lieu ce dimanche 23 septembre avec vous
françois lucas
bonsoir alors j'ai envie de vous poser
une première question le cheval c'est
une valeur sûre dans les yvelines à dire
ça tout à fait c'est d'ailleurs le
deuxième département français il ya
vingt-trois mille licenciés
donc comme il ya environ 100
départements voyez ça veut dire qu'on
aurait 2 millions 300 mille licenciés à
la fédération alors que nous en avons
700 milles et ce qui nous fait quand
même le troisième rang de la fête des
fédérations sportives avant devant nous
nous avons le football et le tennis il
vit alors dans le département des
yvelines le conseil général collaborent
bien pour développer l'équitation ya un
comité départemental d'équitation août a
fait 25 ans que vous restez en plateau
avec et puis comme tous les jeudis vous
le savez c'est la chronique économique
elle est présentée par alain castet
bonsoir à lille encerclant par l'est
notamment
oui tout à fait parce qu'on en avait
parlé la semaine dernière les chiffres
de l'emploi se sont envolés un fin
juillet en dépassant la barre des trois
millions de demandeurs d'emploi en
france et les premiers touchés ce sont
les intérimaires j'aurais en plateau un
des responsables du fast c'est le fonds
d'action sociale pour le travail
temporaire qui nous expliquera toutes
les aides qui existent pour ce statut
qui est souvent jugée précaire on vous
retrouve dans un gros quart d'heure en
plateau avec nous dans cette suite on
parlera également de la croix rouge et
des gestes qui sauvent et sera enfin
question de littérature avec mighty
goldman son nouveau roman s'appelle
couleur bleu lavande et parle évidemment
d'amour mais en attendant retour sur les
faits marquants de cette actualité du
jeudi 20 septembre
des retards dans les transports ce jeudi
des trains supprimés un trafic perturbé
pendant toute la matinée en cause une
rupture du fil d'alimentation pour aider
et conseiller des intérimaires alice
vous l'a dit
existe le faste le fond des de travail
travailleurs temporaires et pour se
faire connaître cet organisme organise
des réunions d'information à la cité des
métiers de trappes
pendant cette semaine de la mobilité
nous proposons le portrait de saint
quentinois qui choisissent des modes de
transports alternatifs pour se rendre à
leur travail
exemple vous le voyez en images avec
michel bérenger qui lui a opté pour la
marche à pied et puis le petit et le
grand le club de football d'elancourt a
signé un beau partenariat avec l aj
auxerre
l'objectif améliorer la formation
sportive et éducative des jeunes joueurs
mais d'abord retour donc sur ces retards
dans les transports c'était ce matin à
les usagers ont souffert à la verrière
certains ont même dû faire demi tour
faute de pouvoir trouver un train
reportage avec anthony rech
7h30 ce jeudi matin une des deux voies
de rer c au niveau de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines connaît un défaut
d'alimentation un train reste bloqué la
situation a duré une partie de la
matinée mais les voyageurs ont pu
repartir avec des retards de 10 à 15
minutes environ
la sncf assure que le trafic devrait
reprendre son cours progressivement qui
a été perturbé je pense qu'on pourra
faire une réparation provisoire qui
s'achèvera je pense en début d'après
midi ce qui ne permettra d'assurer un
trafic quasi normal pour la pointe de
soirée et ensuite on fait une réparation
défini
dans la nuit nous permettra d'avoir à
nouveau la plénitude de nos
installations de vale lignes de
transilien n et u ont également été
perturbés sur les quais les voyageurs
ont été informés très tôt de la
situation et la sncf a distribué aux
usagers restés bloqués ce mode excuse
pour justifier le retard des salariés
l'association laurette fugain à 10 ans
est une association qui est donc été
créée en septembre 2002 à lévis un nom
après le décès de laurette fugain d'une
leucémie et depuis 10 ans l'association
se bat pour soutenir la recherche
médicale un grand concert est organisé
ce lundi soir à l'olympia et pour en
parler avec nous par téléphone delphine
hoffman bonsoir vous êtes responsable de
communication au sein de l'association
laurette fugain
alors d'abord un mot sur cette
association quel est son but j'ai dit
soutenir la recherche médicale et
d'aider les familles tout à fait
l'association laurette fugain fait la
quête annexe vivent des glyphes ans et
d'avancer dans la vie de contrôler le
ferry nous avons trois options
principales d'abord nous sommes un
contributeur défense yellow financement
de la recherche médicale sur les leviers
comme vous l'avez dit nous menons
régulièrement des actions fortes en
faveur de la mobilisation autour des
différents dont deux lits il parle ici
des demandes et donc la quête don de
moelle osseuse dénombré dire c'est pas
nous c'est pas seulement le don de sang
est normal de tous les dons qui peuvent
être utiles aux patients et pour
l'égaler fut tout simplement de
s'impliquer de faire un petit geste pour
leur permettre de et puis une troisième
mission sur l'implication concrète sur
l'aide aux patients et à leurs proches
par le financement de projets qui
permettent d'améliorer la qualité de vie
des patients
vous l'avez dit à l'association est un
des principaux financeurs de la
recherche ce que vous avez des chiffres
nous fournir bien sûr à fin 2012 nous
aurons à arrêter un peu plus de 4,2
millions d'euros au financement de 90
projets de recherche médicale qui ont
chacun donné lieu à de nombreuses
publications scientifiques la recherche
apparaît parfois comme une nébuleuse
savoir que chacun de ces 90 progrès ce
projet représente un progrès concrets
pour l'anah cliff lee diagnostic et donc
les chances de guérison des patients il
faut il faut du temps pour guérir
évidemment on n'en guérit pas de toute
façon aujourd'hui des leucémies il faut
du temps mais la recherche est
indispensable il existe deux types de la
grille très bien pour les enfants nous
sommes au regret mais effectivement il
ya encore des clips de le fumer sur
lesquels la recherche médicale est
indispensable pour permettre d'arriver
alors un mot aussi sur ce concert est
organisé lundi soir à l'olympia pour
fêter les 10 ans je sais pas si on peut
dire pour fêter les 10 ans en tout cas
moi pour souligner des dix ans
l'association belle opportunité en tout
cas de célébrer de remercier tous ceux
qui nous ont aidé et je fais des
premières années et puis d'un autre côté
de mettre en perspective tous les élèves
qui vous attendent pour les dix ans à
venir
on a la chance d'avoir des artistes à
fait exceptionnel pour cet anniversaire
un petit peu exceptionnel et symbolique
de 10 ans donc ira aussi bien les
chanteurs des musiciens vous avez des
noms enrique des danseurs vous avez des
mires une hausse à venir
bah écoutez je peux vous citer quelques
noms il faut très nombreux ils ont
répondu très généreusement à l'appel de
l'association qui roule à m l'arena le
rendait si jean marie bigard michel
boujenah jeanne cherhal julien clerc
gérard larcher
gad elmaleh c'est haïti alexis figurent
marie fugain steve hewitt la lis jamais
les valeurs européennes pierre calme
vous allez faire vous allez faire un
concerto de sava toute la nuit alors
deux questions la durée de la nuit ça va
être un très très beau spectacle je
pense à un très beau moment d'émotion
qui est positif comme l'aiment la
dernière session il reste des places
pour ce concert très peu près toujours
là il faut se dépêcher de revoir de
l'aventuré de prendre le départ immédiat
d'accord merci beaucoup a répondu à nos
questions et puis donc je rappelle le
concert pour les dix ans de
l'association laurette fugain ce sera
donc ce lundi soir à l'olympia et pour
mieux parler encore de l'association je
vous propose d'écouter sa présidente et
fondatrice stéphanie fugain à travers ce
clip de l'association
on pense souvent qu'il suffit d'être
traités dans de bons hôpitaux par de
bons médecins pour avoir une chance de
guérir lorsque ma fille laurette est
hospitalisé nous avons découvert qu'un
malade atteint de leucémie a besoin
régulièrement de don du sang de
plaquettes et parfois d'un don de moelle
osseuse sens et dont aucun traitement
n'est possible
c'est en hommage à leur est et pour tous
les malades qui se bat aujourd'hui que
l'association laurette fugain a été
créée en septembre 2002 elles luttent
activement contre la leucémie
autour de trois missions principales
l'association agit au quotidien pour
faire prendre conscience qu'en donnant
notre sens nos plaquettes ou notre
moelle osseuse
chacun d'entre nous peut aider de façon
immédiate et concrète ceux qui se
battent au quotidien contre la maladie
le but étant de faire évoluer les
comportements pour que l'absence de dons
ne soit plus un obstacle à la guerre
nous travaillons pour faire passer le
message plus grand nombre sur le terrain
et avec le soutien des médias
nos antennes régionales de toulouse
bordeaux nice lyon et marseille font
également un travail de sensibilisation
formidable
et pour donner
nous récoltons des fonds pour financer
des projets de recherche médicale contre
la leucémie
le conseil scientifique et médicale de
l'association sélectionne des projets
porteurs d'espoir que l'association peut
financer grâce aux dons qu'elle reçoit
de nombreux projets retenus par notre
équipe ont déjà été publiées dans des
magazines scientifiques
c'est un excellent démarrage mais le
chemin à parcourir est encore long
l'association récompense aussi les
jeunes chercheurs et des équipes
infirmière au travers de la remise de
deux prix annuel
je t'aime sourire mon coeur
l'association met en place des projets
de solidarité afin d'améliorer le
confort matériel et moral pour proposer
des sorties des moments d'évasion aux
malades et à leurs familles des jeunes
oh
les cours donnés
tout le monde